merci madame la présidente le premier
amendement ils lisent à revenir au pass
sanitaire au lieu du pass vaccinale pas
faut parler clairement bon donc voilà on
porte on peut continuer la discussion
sur chaque amendement sur cette question
et on n'en sortira pas nous on a
expliqué pourquoi on pensé que c'était
mal fondées que l'obligation fonderait
le principe est donc après effectivement
la discussion très claire elle est un
peu confuse dont comptant 200 ha en rond
l'amendement numéro 3
le problème c'est que c'est un
amendement qui vise encore une fois
discréditer le vaccin derrière des
arguments néo scientifique le rapporteur
l'a dit la connaissance et se construit
ce vaccin a des très bonnes qualités il
protège très bien des formes graves et
les moins bons sur d'autres choses ça
dure et d'immunisation elle n'est pas
très bonne et on espère que les vaccins
suivants seront meilleurs effectivement
ce sera pas 4 mois 6 mois et 8 mois j'en
sais rien ce sera plus long et puis par
ailleurs iront pas autre façon
satisfaisante la chaîne de transmission
il ne fait que réduire donc
effectivement il n'est pas excellent et
vous à partir de là vous apporter des
amendements il faut lire vos exposé des
motifs qui visent à le discréditer
ce que je veux dire c'est que le
ministre répond régulièrement
parlementaire et d'une façon que nous
soutenons sur cette question mais moi je
voudrais que le ministre réponde aussi
publiquement à ceux qui tiennent ces
propos et depuis quelques jours le
directeur de l'institut hospitalo
universitaires méditerranée le
professeur out tient des propos qui
discrédite le vaccin cet institut est
financé largement sur fonds publics ça
devrait être le vaisseau amiral des
maladies infectieuses en france c'est la
boussole qui indique le sud et le
maintien de divers out à la direction de
cette ia chu est un scandale national
ils décrivent ibiliz notre politique
sanitaire il désorienté français il
alimente le discours ans d'yvan il faut
prendre vos responsabilités monsieur le
premier ministre monsieur le ministre
pardon encore une fois le même lapsus
décidément il faut prendre vos
responsabilités lui répondre
publiquement
si monsieur juillet
[Musique]